japan's defense minister nobor kishi was
given a tour of the uk's largest and
most powerful warship the hms queen
elizabeth as it docked near tokyo
the ship leads two destroyers two
frigates a submarine and two support
ships which set sail from britain in may
london says the so-called carrier strike
group is part of the uk's new tilt
toward the region the visit to japan is
hugely important and symbolic for us
i think the first time
since the late 1990s that a uk aircraft
carrier has been alongside in japan
and i think it's the best
evidence that you can see of our
commitment
to the indo-pacific region its arrival
comes in the face of increasing chinese
military activity in the south china sea
beijing claims most of the contested
waters territory also claimed by many of
its neighbors including vietnam and the
philippines
japan says china is its main national
security threat and says intensifying
chinese activity around taiwan has
created a sense of crisis
beijing considers the self-ruled island
a rogue chinese province
chinese ships have shadowed the british
fleet beijing has warned the uk against
provocation
we hope relevant countries will play a
constructive role in promoting peace and
stability in the asia pacific rather
than doing the opposite
the uk isn't the only nation conducting
exercises in the region
the u.s and several of its other allies
have recently sailed ships through the
waterway china has responded by
announcing a new maritime law requiring
ships carrying a certain type of cargo
including submersibles or radioactive
material to report to chinese
authorities analysts say the move is
part of beijing's efforts to establish
jurisdiction over the south china sea
chinese experts say the law updates
existing regulations and is focused on
safety
the ships carrying dangerous cargos
especially those radioactive materials
and those toxic materials uh are
different from
from 40 years ago so i think it's
becoming a more common
state practice of coastal states to
promulgate its own laws and regulations
regarding these dangerous ships passing
through its territorial sea dr yen says
beijing considers the british fleet's
presence in the south china sea to be
unfriendly but the warships have so far
steered clear of islands claimed by
china
their mission will continue until the
end of the year
katrina u al jazeera beijing